We'll conclude our discussion of mismatch
by looking at the impact of hygiene on
our microbiota and its consequences
for health and disease.
The idea is here we're stimulated by
seeing certain patterns both in space and
in time that signaled the changes in
our microbiota might be effecting the
incidence of autoimmune disease.
There may be particular roles for worms
in this relationship and therefore we're
going to look at a bit more detail than
how worms might be interacting with the
immune system.
It is possible that some autoimmune
diseases might be treatable with worms,
but it is a risky trade off and evidence
so far is mixed on how effective it
might be. The clinical trials
have not yet been successful,
so let's return for a moment to the
industrial revolution in that second
epidemiological transition.
At that point,
when we went through
urbanization into modern cities,
we entered an environment with soap,
with washed food, with less mud,
and with chlorinated water.
We have less oral fecal transmission
and less contact with farm animals.
At the same time,
antibiotics reduced our exposure to all
kinds of bacteria and anti hill Mythics.
That is drugs against worms and clean
water have reduced our exposure to
parasitic worms.
We encounter less helicobacter
mycobacterium Salmonella
toxoplasma and Hefei
than we did previously.
So our Microbiota has been simplified,
is less varied
because our environment is cleaner.
Okay.
Now what are the consequences?
If we look at a map of the world where
we have good information and we contrast
the postindustrial countries here
in blue with large populations,
countries where most people are
living outside of cities in red.
What we find is the post industrial
countries have high rates of type one
diabetes and a few parasites,
and these countries in red that have
large rural populations and poor access to
antibiotics have low rates of type one
diabetes and high rates of diseases that
are caused by worms.
If we look in time over the
last half of the 20th century,
infectious diseases declined
rapidly in incidents.
So this is hepatitis a, tuberculosis,
mumps, measles, rheumatic fever,
all declining at the same time.
The immune disorders,
rose, multiple sclerosis, Crohn's disease,
type one diabetes and asthma all rose
dramatically in the last half of the 20th
century.
So there's an inverse relationship between
the incidents of infectious disease
and immune pathology.
Yeah.
This prompted the idea that autoimmune
diseases and the other immune pathologies
could be mediated by worms and people
began to do experiments on worms.
Here we have the particular kind of warm
and the auto immune disease that was
investigated experimentally.
So just a soma has been shown to reduce
the risk of autoimmune encephalomyelitis
and graves thyroiditis.
True Cure.
A Sueess has been shown in mice to reduce
the incidence of inflammatory bowel
disease and so forth.
So there has been some
experimental evidence in mice
showing the treatment with
worms or with worm eggs can reduce
the risk of autoimmune disease.
So these experiments were stimulated
by those patterns in space and time.
Now
that suggests that one could carry out
therapy with pig whipworms in humans.
The choice of the pig whipworm was led
by the idea that you needed something
that would not be a itself,
a pathogen in humans,
but might produce enough interaction
with the immune system to trigger the,
uh,
protective response.
So preliminary trials of
a cocktail of Pickwick,
whipworm eggs produce some mixed results
in people with ulcerative colitis.
Then large scale clinical
trials were implemented.
They were called off in 2013 when those
who are on the treatments were not doing
any better than those
who are on the placebos.
A case control study of people with and
without naturally occurring pierce a
team.
He has indicated that having parasites
in your body slowed the progress of
multiple sclerosis and treating the PR.
The parasites accelerated it here.
All we have on the x axis time in months.
So this whole period here,
it's five years to there and then it's
about another on two and a half years out
to here. The black line is
people who are uninfected.
The red line is people who are infected.
The Blue Line is people who have been
treated for their infection and the y axis
is the number of lesions detected in
the brain that are characteristic of
multiple. So there are really
two things to see here.
One is that the patients entering
where either uninfected are infected,
but they all had the preliminary
symptoms of multiple sclerosis.
Those who are uninfected
rapidly developed symptoms.
Okay.
Those who were infected were much slower.
They hardly developed any further symptoms
at all of multiple sclerosis. However,
these are natural worm infections.
These are not therapeutic egg, uh,
treatments with cocktails.
And so some of the patients really began
to suffer from their worm infections.
They were pathogenic and serious.
They were treated for
their worm infections here.
And as soon as the worms were cleared out,
you can see that are symptoms of multiple
sclerosis rapidly rose to about the
same level of those people who had
lacked worms right from the beginning.
Okay.
So there is some suggestion that worms
are providing protection against the auto
immune disease.
That leads to the issue of how they might
be interacting with the immune system.
It might be simple homeostasis.
So the immune response produced by
the worm infection might simply be
overlapping with something like
the tissue repair response.
Okay.
It could be a downregulation of the
immune response by the host to avoid
inflammatory damage.
In a sustained infection in such a
broad way that allergic and autoimmune
reactions are also dampens?
Yeah,
it could be that by elevating
circulating antibody levels,
both specific and nonspecific antibodies
in response to the worm infection would
dilute the allergen specific
antibodies and saturate reception.
Oh at receptors on mast
cells and eosinophils.
Okay.
And it could also be that
there was interference with
specific signals by worms
to evade and suppress the immune system
with reduction of immune pathologies is
an unintended byproduct.
That is the one that I think that is
most likely because worms have been under
strong natural selection to be able to
suppress the immune system so that they
can stay in the body of the
host and continue to reproduce.
All four processes are possible.
They have not yet been ruled out.
The fourth seems to be the most likely.
However,
worm therapy is a risky kind
of trade off in the tropics.
Worm infections increased susceptibility
to the Berkey losis, AIDS,
malaria and other infectious diseases.
So giving people worms in the tropics
is a bad idea because it could very well
make them die for other reasons.
Okay.
Worm infections also reduced the
protection protection offered by vaccines.
Okay.
The symptoms of worm infections
themselves can cause distress and they may
become life threatening.
So although some individuals have reported
improvements in the symptoms of an
inflammatory bowel disease when infected
by hookworms hookworm infections
themselves can produce serious pathology.
So worm infection is a risky trade off.
Clinical trials have not
yet been successful to phase
two clinical trials that
we're using.
Pig whipworm eggs to treat Crohn's disease
were discontinued when the treatments
were not doing any
better than the placebos.
It might be that worms really are
mediating auto immune disease,
but that warm therapy is only effective
when the worms can establish and during
infections and cause pathogenic
effects themselves. Now,
if that's the case,
the cost benefit balance
of warm treatments must be
looked at very carefully and
it may be that we are going to have to
do something like domesticate worms or
put them through a program as we would
with the virus to try to produce an
attenuated live virus. If we could
produce an attenuated warm treatment,
then that might be effective.
So to summarize,
our bodies coevolved with a diverse
Microbiota with which we've had both
positive and negative interactions.
When those commensals are removed,
our immune systems respond
inappropriately and we get allergy,
asthma,
and autoimmune disease.
Some mechanisms are now understood,
but the search for therapies
using biological agents has
not yet been successful.
So to conclude on the
general problem of mismatch,
our bodies are clearly mismatched
suit to a sedentary lifestyle,
to a post industrial diet,
to a lack of exposure to parasitic
worms and to altered exposure to other
microorganisms. Some of the
resulting diseases, obesity,
high blood pressure,
cardiovascular disease,
and type two diabetes can be
improved with Diet and exercise.
That should be the first
line of defense for others.
The immune fatalities effective
therapies are desperately needed,
but they are not yet available. Insights
from mismatch may help to find them.